(bright music)
- [Narrator] These photos show some
of Kim Jong Un's most
iconic public appearances
as North Korea's leader
over the past 12 years.
(bright music)
From 2011, when he came to power
following his father's death,
to one of the many events he attended
as North Korea emerged from
the Coronavirus Pandemic.
Jenny Town is the director of 38 North,
a North Korea focused website.
She has been studying the
subtle shifts in Kim's attire
over the years.
- Kim Jong Un is the face of North Korea
and the persona that he
puts out, really tells you
how he wants the people to see him.
- [Narrator] We look
at what can be gleaned
about the changing state of North Korea
from Kim's wardrobe choices.
(crowd cheers)
And what his different looks signal
about the future of his regime.
(North Korean singing)
Kim Jong Un's public appearances
are all carefully choreographed
and often packed with symbolism.
(horse hooves patter)
In late 2019, Kim was pictured
riding on a white horse
through Mount Peaktu.
The mountain is one of the
country's most sacred sites,
a place many North Koreans believe
to be where the first
Korean kingdom was founded.
- These were special
horses that were gifted
to the Kim family.
Only the leaders have
these special horses.
They would only have a photo shoot here
if it was a very important
message they were trying to send.
This was, the North Koreans were going
to do it in their own way,
reasserting that self-reliance attitude.
(crowd cheers and applauds)
- [Narrator] Descendants
of the Kim family,
namely Kim Jong Un's late
grandfather, Kim Il Sung,
and father, Kim Jong Il,
seen standing on the
mountain in this painting,
have run the country since its founding
more than 70 years ago.
In another painting of the two
former North Korean leaders
on the peak,
shows there's one outfit that's common
between all three Kims.
The Mao suit.
(bright music)
The pointed collar, to the neck buttoning,
and the four pockets in the front.
(crowd cheers)
The suit is known as
the Mao suit in the West
because they were
popularized during the reign
of Mao Zedong, the founder
of communist China.
(military chanting)
It's one of Kim's most
common wardrobe choices.
- You can see here,
especially at the beginning
of Kim Jong Un's tenure as the leader,
you saw him wear this quite often.
(brass band plays)
- [Narrator] Kim wore
the Mao suit when he met
with Chinese leader Xi Jinping,
during his first trip abroad
since coming to power, in 2018.
(glasses clink)
He also wore similar outfits in talks
with different world leaders
at a time when Pyongyang was negotiating
nuclear disarmament with the US.
- [Donald] My friend.
- He met with Donald Trump.
He had this typical Mao suit on
that was very representative
of the North Korean identity.
It might've been, yeah,
to differentiate himself
from the other world leaders
and to maintain that
North Korean presence.
(bright music)
(crowd cheers)
- [Narrator] But Kim also
likes to wear Western suits,
especially while attending
events back home.
Town says this shows Kim wants
to portray a different image
for the domestic audience.
- In one of his New Year's
speeches, he started
to wear these Western suits
in these formal meetings,
and especially the important ones.
There wasn't the Mao suit
anymore, domestically.
You saw much more of this global persona,
much more of this Western style look.
I think there was a
level of confidence here
and a trying to portray that
the country was moving forward
and especially on equal terms
with the rest of the world.
(bright music)
- [Narrator] Kim's
appearance before, during,
and after the COVID-19 pandemic
reflects his political messaging.
(rocket ignites)
As negotiations over North
Korea's denuclearization
collapsed in 2019-
(crowd cheers)
Kim made frequent public outings in a bid
to rally the country.
- He was out doing site
visits like this one here,
like he's, you know, out with the people
in a pretty typical attire
that's seasonally appropriate,
but casual, to try and, you know,
connect with the people more.
There was a lot of note
that he was out doing these site visits
maybe about every couple of weeks.
(bright music)
(digital thermometer beeps)
- [Narrator] But when COVID-19 began
to spread across the globe
and North Korea closed its borders,
Kim barely appeared in public.
- Towards the middle to end of
the pandemic we did see sort
of a new Kim Jong Un emerge.
You can see, especially in this picture,
how much thinner he is,
especially compared to this one here.
One of the narratives that went on at
that time domestically was
that the people were also
so concerned that he
had lost so much weight
and that he was suffering
for the people along with the people,
during a very difficult
time for the country.
(ceremonial music)
- [Narrator] But as the
pandemic came to an end
and North Korea began
its gradual reopening,
Kim started to look
more like his old self.
- There was definitely a shift
in the public narrative in Kim
Jong Un's priorities as well.
A real shift towards more
military development.
(missile launches)
We saw a lot of new missile systems
being tested and developed.
(missile ignites)
We saw a lot more military activity
when the economy wasn't doing so good.
That does convey a sense of optimism.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] In March, 2022,
North Korean state media
released a heavily edited video
showing Kim wearing sunglasses
and a black leather jacket
as he oversaw the test
of the new intercontinental
ballistic missile.
- For him to have come
out in this bomber jacket,
it really set the tone of trying
to create his own persona,
trying to look more Western.
Maybe it was trying to
look kind of like Top Gun,
(soldier screams order)
(missile ignites)
- [Narrator] The Top Gun style
jacket marked a shift away
from the outfits that symbolized the cult
of personality around his
father and grandfather.
- This is a good kind of
depiction of the evolution
of Kim Jong Un, and here we see him
with a much more traditional look,
trying to look like his grandfather,
trying to emulate that kind
of traditional persona.
And here he is.
He is his own man, right?
Like he's had a lot of successes,
especially in the military
front and the missile front,
and things that his father
and grandfather hadn't
been able to accomplish.
(crowd cheers)
And we have seen Kim Jong
Un throughout this period
as he develops his own, not only style,
but also his own style of leadership.
(upbeat music)